oh hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to douchebag beats club I
gained mass for no reason enhance your
style
meet other douchebags hear your chicks
nice dog is this me okay
alright then oh this is the main mint
what the hell Oh Oh No thank you I'm
okay I'm alright I don't know what I'm
doing do your first workout Wow buddy no
pain no gain that's the secret of my
universe how about your universe shuts
the [__] up are you all impressed by my
amazing dragon skills no useful why that
is true cardio does kill your games
Sears access is owned by the tablet
click the map icon there's so many
bright lights and colors this is correct
the bar oh that's where I'm at nice
booty I guess is it I'm guessing the
premium thing about douchebags is Oh
no pain no gain producer my you know
could you
shut the [__] up about your universe
sorry I just
I caught a horrible disease you wouldn't
want it don't come near me you got
healthy you got healthier that's what
happened this like huniepop did I do the
sex did I sex it up oh my god get
intimate with this reality star which
one oh Jesus
you okay dude try believe worth it
press the fashion girl
did I get money for that I got money for
beans all right you know hey whatever it
is what it is can I get
what does target a quarte plan oh I feel
like this game is changing me I feel
like I'm slowly accepting the douche
life I mean I don't know what that means
entirely legal boosters will help you
gain mastering workout Oh energy bar
protein shake isn't broken for my face
maybe way something your brain weighs
nothing
stop oh yeah that's right I can go to
the shop I need more swag hey lady are
you okay I have some like poopy
like they can boot like your dad you
know oh yeah I guess good oh man Wow
I don't think I'm going for the style I
was hoping for yeah well whatever this
looks properly douche tastic Oh
now I'm customer can you just okay I get
it I'm a douche facial hair
oh oh wow that is incredibly douchey
just the pencil oh yeah I think I'm
starting to like it I'm certain oh wow I
changed my mind
let's change my mind I changed my mind
I'm gonna go with this yeah that looks
properly boost up how about my kicks I
need some flippin kicks yo I need I need
to slip okay oh yeah oh is that the
Phoenix right here style I think that is
oh yeah this is I don't wonder shoes
I'm gonna go Phoenix right I'm swaggin
it up baby yeah I'm a real douche now
what are you thinking me now baby how do
you like me cranking my yank what
happened I really do think
that the unbelievable thumping bass is
starting to affect my brain what is this
what is it
oh damn it Emma enough did I did I do it
again am I not playing the first game of
oh [__] well okay how about back to the
bar
I wonder what's going on here hey whoa
win the armwrestling Cup
how do I do that Wow oh my god are you
okay sir are you the Hulk did you stop
me transformer are you okay what is
wrong with your feet you're welcome I'm
the best time the douchiest that douche
teed up I juiced it to maximum capacity
bring on the chance to brag okay hang
out with the trainer okay
I hang out do you mean hang out what are
you working on that seems like a bit
extreme also [__] you I actually have to
grind up my new shoes cuz I'm not
douchey enough I need to do chartres I
need to do SH live free or Deus hard I
need to do [__] up
oh oh oh something happened to me
yeah don't mind my voice crankiness
install the steroids I've been shoving
into my can I get some tats why do you
sound like you're selling meth oh those
are oh this is nice
I don't even know what that means I
think whoa hey it's me alright you
barely see it under my towering Tower of
hats oh god I'm so horrible oh I'm so
horrifying oh what's wrong with me
everything wrong with me let's go talk
to trainer no I don't mean to criticize
but you don't last very long that was
maybe half a second I mean I'm just
gonna say that right now if you take me
into your van I'm gonna be very upset
yeah yeah beat Samantha at the shots
game
okay what am I supposed to do oh yeah
I'm the best of the game of the drinking
this junk drunk Ryu
okay bye I guess hey my famous Oh screw
you don't you know who I am
markiplier I'm douche number one what
are you okay thanks bro how's it going
bro again with you what body
I don't know it's talking do you not
have arms Lee are you okay what happened
here stay flexed how do I do that I
don't know if this is doing good I'm
trying my best
I was alone well anything to stroke my
ego I guess dang I got David get it
ticket okay no one's here no one cares
where's all the ladies dope never I
would never touch this type of ethical
let's go to a show I don't care what
that was I'm going in douche hello how
how do I do this
do you not see what sky that was
impressive right me click to boink yeah
yeah
2.0 miking clicking spots aren't you
impressed my eyes coordination is
jumping for no reason here we go okay I
think I'm having a seizure I didn't get
enough my muscles okay hi oh that's not
what I look like
this is a bunch of bull did did are one
don't you know oh god why do I have to
do more I have spent nearly 30 minute
over 30 minutes now playing this tragedy
of a game and I like okay I changed my
mind this is good real boring real quick
cuz I gotta grind up some money to get
my swagger Rooney's at 100% roadie and
then then I'm gonna get the fly as
lady reach I'm gonna take her down to
the discotheque and we're gonna dance
the night away the eighties have douches
too I wonder what I'll use this amazing
practice for get over here superstar
whatever your name is I don't even care
any words give come on screw you you
douchebag god damn I'm gonna wasted my
life on that and that's the bad David
show me banging the reality star even
though it didn't show rang in everyone
bunch of bull oh that's so stupid
oh that's so stupid oh that's so stupid
hey I'm not the one to decide that you'd
guys let me know if that was stupid too
because I feel stupid or for doing it so
thank you everybody so much for watching
check out the annotation more cool
videos that I've done probably cooler
than this and as always old see you in
the next video
my cheeks hurt from smiling so much